chers collègues en application de
l'article 13 de la constitution nous
entendons ce matin monsieur jean
françois delfraissy candidat proposé par
le président de la république pour le
renouvellement de son mandat à la
présidence du comité consultatif
national d'éthique ccne je salue les
commissaires qui assistent à cette
réunion à distance
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat et 10 possibles et disponibles en
vidéo à la demande
je rappelle que cette nomination ne sera
effective qu'en l'absence d'opposition
des commissions parlementaires
compétentes de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
dans les formes prévues par la
constitution
si l'addition des votes négatifs de
chaque commission représentait au moins
trois cinquièmes des suffrages exprimés
le président de la république ne
pourrait pas procédé à cette nomination
à l'issue de l'audition nous procéderons
immédiatement au vote pour lequel les
délégations ne sont pas autorisés ainsi
qu'aux dépouillement de manière
simultanée avec l'assemblée nationale
qui a procédé à cette même audition plus
tôt dans la matinée
monsieur delfraissy vous êtes devenu
l'une des figures la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire
vous êtes sans doute plus connu mais ce
n'est pas une critique de nos
concitoyens en votre qualité de
président du conseil scientifique que
comme président du ccn heures même s'il
sait c'est une institution majeure que
nous nous connaissons bien vous avez
vous avez été nommé le 4 janvier 2017
pour un mandat de deux ans et notre
commission vous a entendu à ce titre en
décembre 2016 puis en janvier 2019
alors je vous laisse la parole pour
présenter votre bilan et les
perspectives que vous envisagez pour le
conseil pour les prochaines années avant
que nos collègues ne vous adressent
leurs questions voilà donc je vous
laisse la parole à monsieur le président
merci même la présidente bonjour à tous
clément rapidement me
me présentait donc jean françois
delfraissy je suis professeur émérite de
médecine suis spécialiste en immunologie
et dans les maladies émergentes
j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans le domaine
du vih sida mais pas que je suis un
médecin engagé et un médecin de de
terrain j'ai d'ailleurs toujours une
consultation à l'hôpital bicêtre qui est
mon ancien capitale j'ai contribué ce
point ça à trois points majeurs dans ma
carrière médicale qui est quasiment
résoudre le problème de la transmission
du vih de la mère à l'enfant en traitant
les mamans par des antirétroviraux j'ai
contribué à l'arrivée dès la définition
des trithérapies dans le vih
puis participer largement à la mise en
place des traitements éradicateurs de
l'hépatite c le les autorités françaises
moment confié trois grandes missions
indépendamment de de cet aspect médical
et de recherche
la direction de la mairesse l'agent
saint-charles de recherches sur le sida
et les hépatites virales puis ensuite
c'est les gouvernements successifs ont
nommée déléguée interministérielle de la
lutte contre ebola et enfin vous l'avez
rappelé madame la présidente
mon nom mais entre guillemets président
du comité consultatif national d'éthique
ya maintenant quatre ans et vous savez
que le président dans le modèle actuel
avant la révision des lois bioéthiques
et non mais pour des périodes de deux
ans renouvelable est d'ailleurs le mans
un changement dans la loi de bioéthique
à ce sujet alors au cours de ces quatre
ans
il ya eu deux périodes la première de
deux ans de 2017 et 2018 a été la
préparation puis la mise en place des
états généraux de la bioéthique
c'était la première fois que le ccn avec
cette mission je les découvertes à vrai
dire en arrivant et il a fallu monter
les états généraux de la bioéthique
comment faire réfléchir avec nos
concitoyens sur des grands enjeux de
bioéthique avec des sujets à la fois
scientifique très difficile mais aussi
des sujets si on sait société et comment
aider à réfléchir et à construire
finalement des éléments de penser
d'intelligence collective entre d'une
part la vision bien sûr des experts et
des sachants qui est nécessaire mais
aussi la vision citoyenne avant que
soient prises des décisions politiques
dans le cadre du vote de la loi et c'est
ce que j'appelle je pense fondamentales
y compris après cette crise que vit dans
cette vision de démocratie en santé les
les deux plus donc les deux premières
années ont été consacrées au tour de je
dirais de des états généraux et et de la
révision de la loi et davies en place de
la loi d'éclairage entre guillemets je
suis venu plusieurs fois devant vous
devant des commission ad-hoc pour
expliquer où nous en étions dans la
réflexion du ce et cm 2 et on
particulier dans un dé à vis du ccn qui
était pour éclairer entre guillemets
donner une sorte de boussole sur quelle
société dans quelle société voulons-nous
vivre dans les années qui viennent
compte tenu des avancées massive dans
certains domaines de la science
et je vous rappelle que la science est
fondamentale et qu'elle n'est pas
suffisante et que toutes les avancées de
la science ne sont pas bonnes à prendre
en tant que tel alors ensuite l'un des
deux le deuxième point qui a été fait
pendant cette période et est de
positionner le ccn au niveau
international plus qu'il ne l'était
c'est à dire qu'il y ait une voix
françaises de la bioéthique française
qu'ils soient présentes à l' oms fait
partie du comité d'éthique de la ms à
l'europe est un des membres du csn et
candidats actuels pour faire partie du
comité et éthiques
auprès de la commission de bruxelles on
s'est exprimé sur ces aspects
internationaux et en particules certains
d'entre vous se souviennent peut-être
qu'au moment des nouvelles commissions
de la commission européenne il était
abandonnée quand on y pense
avec la crise actuelle il était envisagé
de supprimer un commissaire à la santé
pour le mettre dans le com comme
commissaire uniquement l'innovation et
big pharma poussait beaucoup évidemment
sur ce sujet or la santé c'est bien sûr
s'appuie sur l'innovation
mais la santé c'est bien autre chose
aussi que l'innovation et nous avons
réclamé dans une tribune au monde au nom
du ccn eux que soit conservé un un
commissariat à la santé et ensuite est
arrivé évidemment dans la deuxième
période l'arrivée de kobe 19 le ccnb on
tarn un peu anticipé par beaucoup disent
on l'a aimé quand même et a sorti son
premier avis autour de covin 19 le 13
mars 2020 un vendredi 13 mars c'est à
dire juste dans la période intermédiaire
qui était la première présélection sur
les enjeux éthiques que pouvaient poser
sept grandes crises sanitaires que nous
ne voyons pas tout à fait à l'époque la
dimension qu'elle a pu prendre par la
suite
et à ce moment là je me suis mis en
débord de la présidence du sénat parce
que au même le même jour j'ai été nommé
président du conseil scientifique co
vide et nous reviendrons sur ce problème
de dualité entre la présidence du ccee
et la présidence du conseil scientifique
coheed alors durant cette période le csn
a émis jeudi 7 quel sens large du terme
quelques avis majeur que je voudrais
juste rappeler enfin que j'estime en
tout cas majeurs sur biodiversité santé
santé des migrants et exigence éthique
enjeux éthiques du vieillissement qui
reposait déjà la question est ce que le
modèle est pas d'avs
on sait est il le seul modèle qu'on doit
donner et qu'on doit investir pour nous
pour nos concitoyens et nos plus anciens
numérique et santé quels enjeux éthiques
pour quelles régulations enjeux éthiques
des modifications ciblées du génome à
propos des des nouvelles techniques de
type christophe kass neuf mais pas que
ce n'est pas que l'adoption accroître la
transparence des procédures la clé enfin
de façon plus récentes en novembre 2020
l'accès aux innovations thérapeutiques
les enjeux éthiques
il y en a sorti pendant cette période
environ 14 avis plus des avis concernant
des opinions concernant les enjeux de la
crise mais je reviendrai après et qui
vous montre la vitalité entre guillemets
deux de cette instance
le président n'y est pour rien joue je
suis vraiment dit sa grande modestie
ronde j'ai la chance d'avoir un cce qui
est une instance vraiment qui est une
particularité un peu à la française
d'intelligence collective et de
construction commune entre la fois des
juristes des philosophes des
anthropologues des médecins des
chercheurs et qui construit on arrive
avec une idée et qui construit à une
autre idée parce qu'elle se construit
sous forme d'intelligence collective
alors quelques où va-t-on là maintenant
et pourquoi j'ai souhaité renouveler mon
mandat encore pour une période de deux
ans parce que je souhaiterais
accompagner le ccn eux vers une vision
de d'un cce 2.0 si je peux m'expliquer
comme si je puis m'exprimer comme tel on
est un tout petit peu provocateur en le
disant
parce que fondamentalement le ccn ne
doit pas trop bouger c'est bien clair il
est là avec sa vision de moyen terme de
long terme sa réflexion sur des enjeux
éthiques et c'est ce qui fait sa force
et inversement il doit aussi s'adapter
s'adapter à notre civilisation actuelle
à la vision de nos concitoyens et à la
vision de tout ce qui bouge actuellement
et la loi d'ailleurs de bioéthique si
elle est votée cet été a envisagé le
mouvement est envisagée le mouvement sur
deux de deux grands aspects le premier
c'est comment le ccn peut-il et doit-il
dans ses nouvelles fonctions de
construire le débat bioéthique en
continu au niveau national c'est ce que
nous avons fait lors des états généraux
mais le poursuivre et le faire en
continu et le deuxième aspect c'est
finalement augmenter le périmètre du cce
dans ses thématiques alors assuré le
débat éthique
on a une très belle expérience avec les
états unis robot qui est et ce qu'elle
est certains diront qu'elle n'était pas
suffisante c'était la première fois que
ces scènes ne le faisait il y avait plus
de 350 réunions en région d d d environ
300 auditions un site web un comité
citoyen qui avait été monté autour de
deux états généraux donc déjà des
tentatives entre guillemets je dirais de
s'ouvrir vis-à-vis de la société civile
et des territoires
et c'est quelque chose auquel je tiens
beaucoup car je n en arrivant c'est
celle de c'est à la fois une très bonne
instance un peu parisienne disons pas
suffisamment ouverte sur sur l'ensemble
de nos territoires et un peu je dirais
club d'intello parisien
ce qui est fondamental ce qui est
fondamental pour pour construire la
réflexion il faut surtout lui garder 7,7
cette force qui fait d'ailleurs aussi
son autonomie et son indépendance
mais il est aussi important de commencer
à construire aussi quelque chose d'un
peu plus commun d'un peu plus fluide
avec la société civile sur de grandes
questions auxquelles soit elle
s'intéresse soit elle s'intéresse pas
mais s'intéresse souvent et comme vous
le savez mieux que moi et les français
sont beaucoup plus intelligents comme le
pensent y compris sur des sujets
difficiles et peuvent parfaitement
s'adapter à des grandes questions qui
les regardent ou la santé interpellent
la vie et le type de vie qu'ils vont
avoir ils en ont pleinement conscience
alors pour ça on va s'appuyer on
s'appuie déjà beaucoup sur un réseau qui
existe qui sont les horaires qui sont
donc ces structures de réflexion éthique
au niveau des régions qui ont elles
mêmes leurs réseaux au niveau des
régions donc on construit et qui se sont
regroupés avec un regroupement de
l'ensemble de ses erreurs avec un bureau
qui s'appelle la cnps air-air donc on a
un cce un peu centrales nationales qui
s'appuie pour la construction du débat
public pour la construction de d'un
certain nombre de retours de la part des
citoyens sur un certain nombre de ses
sujets difficiles avec le réseau des
horaires et nous avons déjà commencé à
construire ça de façon très très forte
on l'avait fait au moment des états
généraux on la refait et vous verrez
dans l'est dans les 48 heures sortie une
opinion du ccn sur trois objets trois
opinions à propos de problèmes porté par
les vaccins
autour d'eux à la fois l'obligation
vaccinale le pass sanitaires ou que
faire vis-à-vis de nos anciens qui n'ont
pas souhaité se faire vacciner dans les
ehpad et vous verrez que cette
construction de cette opinion du ccn eux
s'est fait en collaboration avec la cne
ray ray avec un retour de ceux qui
cèdent et des avis qui ont été donnés en
région sas a rejoint la vision que vous
comprenez j'ai depuis longtemps parce
que je devais construite dans ma
carrière médicale qui est cette vision
de que la santé doit doit s'inscrire
dans un schéma de démocratie en santé
que les médecins nous ne sommes qu'un
des éléments que le citoyen bien sûr à
son a son mot à dire sur finalement à la
fois souvent sur sa propre maladie et on
oublie mais aussi sur la construction
même de la vision de la santé qu'on veut
bien lui donner
le second point est sûre à construire je
dirais pour les deux années qui viennent
c'est l'augmentation du périmètre du ccn
eux qui est con qui est prévu dans la
loi et en particulier sur des sujets de
type environnement et santé pas que
numérique et santé mais environnement et
santé allons nous avions déjà émis un
avis sur le type sur sur ce sujet et il
ya également le l'enjeu du numérique qui
adore la surdouée m'arrêter deux minutes
pour vous faire part de mes points
d'interrogation il est partagé avec vous
le nôtre anciens premiers ministres
edouard philippe a confié au cce dans
une lettre de mission de juillet 2019
l'idée de construire un comité pilote du
numérique c'est à dire non pas seulement
du numérique en santé mais du numérique
en général en disant que c'était une
nouvelle vision scientifique ou ou en
tout cas une nouvelle évolution que les
enjeux éthiques
évidemment ce était là et a souhaité
s'appuyer sur l'expérience un peu du ccn
qui a maintenant de nombreuses années
derrière lui pour aider à construire ce
comité pilote alors c'est ce qu'on a
fait copine et de comités pilotes
tournent depuis maintenant quatorze mois
à peu près environ et on commence à
avoir une idée des enjeux on l'a mis à
côté de nous sous l'égide du csn dont
les mêmes locaux avec la même
administration sans armes seulement il a
d'ailleurs sans un moyen supplie son
financement tellement supplémentaires
m'enfin on l'a fait et on se pose
maintenant la question de ouvaton
comment on atterrit à partir de cette
expérience de ce comité pilote de
numérique et en gros il ya deux grandes
solutions qui ne sont pas tranchées que
moi même je n'ai pas tranché que le ccn
lui-même n'a pas tranché qui sont est ce
qu'on fait un comité d'éthique du
numérique
à côté indépendant du ccn standard si je
peux dire qu'il ya 900 l'avantagé on
pourrait partager les mêmes bâtiments
une série de choses ensemble et c'est
enfin coordonner tout ça et avoir même
une série de réunions que l'une ou bien
est-ce qu'on va plus loin et on
construit finalement
une sorte de comité d'éthique un peu
nationale avec des piliers verticaux
dans lequel on aurait le numérique
évidemment le csn biologie et santé et
puis pourquoi pas pour la suite quelque
chose autour d'eux des enjeux éthiques
de l'environnement et pourquoi pas
d'autres d'autres grands sujets qui
pourraient arriver
eh bien je vais vous dire très
franchement c'est ici c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je souhaitais
rester pour construire finir de
construire cette vision et la proposer
bien sûr je pense qu'il faudra passer
par une loi
compte tenu du niveau qu'elle avait été
créée le cce
je n'ai pas d'opinion tranchée à ce jour
je vois bien les avantages de deux
structures on n'aime pas multiplier les
structures ce n'est pas l'ambiance de
multiplier les structures d'avoir une
grande structure avec des pays et
verticaux et sur le papier quelque chose
qui se présente bien et inversement
c'est au nom de quoi une très grosse
structure qui serait le comité d'éthique
nationale qui pourrait quitter son
caractère un peu artisanal que nous
sommes allés vers une structure un peu
de titres plutôt agence est ce que c'est
vraiment ça qu'on soit je n'en suis pas
non plus totalement persuadé donc voyez
je sais c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai vraiment sollicité de
rester deux ans pour finir de construire
et pouvoir ensuite ça va nous engager
c'est le numérique est un élément
fondamental ça va nous engager pour la
suite et c'est un des éléments qui
m'apparaît qui m'apparaît important
enfin bien sûr le cce comme objectif de
poursuivre ce que ce qu'on a déjà
beaucoup démarré avec la vision au
niveau international comme je voulais
rappeler et en particulier aussi sur sur
cet aspect numérique qui étend qui est
en friche où il n'y a pas de comité
d'éthique du numérique dans la majorité
pour ne pas dire dans la totalité des
pays alors que vous savez que le modèle
ccn a été pris en modèle par par
beaucoup de pays et qu'il va même plus
loin le japon envisage de construire une
loi de bioéthique avec des états
généraux de la bioéthique
suite à l'expérience qu'on leur a
présenté donc il y a il ya une vraie je
dirais possibilité de vision française
d'apport français
l'éthique logiquement on devrait sur
certaines questions être partagées
devrait avoir probablement sur quelques
grandes réponse éthique commune de plus
en plus communes au niveau européen
c'est pas le cas vous le savez sur sur
certains sujets il ya des sujets sur
lesquels on avancer ensemble d'autres
sujets on peut mieux faire
c'est à mon avis aussi un enjeu
fondamental pour la place de la france
qui portent quand même qui a porté la
notion même de réflexion éthique depuis
très longtemps et qui doit se situer
entre cette vision très à l'anglo
saxonne et cette vision très très asie
du sud-est hors japon qui est un pays à
part mais où il ya encore une grande et
enfin de grands questionnements éthiques
sur un certain nombre de pays et où
notre vision je dois dire doit être
encore plus appuyé qu'elle ne l'est on
va essayer de profiter du fait que la
france va être président de la
commission européenne afin de de
l'europe pendant la période des six
premiers mois de 2000 22 pour mettre à
l'agenda entre autres de deux agendas
très riche un de portée par parler
français j'ai pour mettre aussi cette
question éthique au coeur du débat
et pourquoi pas d'ailleurs aussi des
conséquences et peut-être qu'on pourra
je l'espère à sion la commencer à
regarder un peu derrière nous par
rapport à la crise à la crise que vit
alors juste pour terminer le ccn pendant
cette période
duco vide je me suis donc en débord du
ccn de la présidence du ccn dès le 13
mars jusqu'au mois de juillet je vous
rappelle que j'avais demandé à quitter
la présidence du conseil scientifique
est d'ailleurs l'arrêt du conseil
scientifique que vides en juillet et que
c'est le sénat et l'assemblée nationale
qui avait souhaité que se poursuivre le
conseil scientifique
vous avez d'ailleurs peut-être
finalement bien fait et
j'avais souhaité donc pouvoir me libérer
pour reprendre la direction du cc alors
gelé reprise à partir du juillet parce
que j'étais en le cce et est en
renouvellement
c'est un processus très compliqué qui on
se croirait quasiment dans courteline
dans la ligue
les lamelles hamlin des méthodes entre
guillemets pour le renouvellement qui
doivent tenir compte de toute une série
de choses c'est ça dure six mois c'est
très long et je ne pouvais pas laisser
le cc 2 je dirais sans un patron à bord
entre guillemets même si ma vice
présidente avait parfaitement géré les
choses autour de la crise qu vide et
donc c'est dans ces conditions que que
j'ai été amené à reprendre la direction
du cce pour leur événement qui a eu lieu
finalement début janvier
alors le ccdh durant toute cette période
a sorti cet avis entre guillemets ou
opinions autour de de la crise et des
enjeux éthiques posés par la crise que
vit j'imagine mais je ne vais pas en
parler maintenant et je répondrai aux
questions qu une des questions que vous
allez me posez c'est évidemment comment
j'envisage à la fois de continuer à
présider le conseil scientifique et puis
de présider le ccn et commence
est ce possible est-ce que
l'indépendance est possible d'écouter si
vous me posez la question je tenterai de
vous répondre
donc
on a le droit d'avoir un tout petit peu
d'humour dans dance est dans cette
période
dans cette difficile il nous en faut
tout ça voilà abap et moi le premier
bien sûr non je voudrais juste donc
répété que le cce tune est une très
belle un sens très très belle instance
peut-être encore un peu méconnue on a
j'ai essayé de la deûle à mettre plus en
avant que qu'elle n'était durant ces
trois dernières années mais peut mieux
faire et c'est ce à quoi je je je
souhaite m'attacher si si vous me
renouvelez il ya cet aspect je voulais
dit autour du numérique qui est un point
important de construction de deux
visions con qu'on doit avoir au niveau
français autour de ça la position de la
france au niveau international qui est
fondamental fondamental que nous
puissions nous exprimer sur un certain
nombre de ces sujets nous sommes enfin
on est on est un des peuples de la
démocratie et les enjeux démocratiques
de l'éthique son sens sur un point tout
à fait essentiel dans cet esprit un
groupe de travail au sein du cce ne
vient d'être montée et soumah demande
autour de 11 jeux éthique de la santé
publique a tiré les leçons et
éventuellement de la crise savait que la
crise est un système de tension terrible
entre nous tous
l'intergénérationnel que ça rejoint
finalement ce qui est l'éthique qui et
quand on pose une question qu'on écoute
et qu'on voit les tensions qui n'est pas
forcément la réponse à la question est
qui est posé sur la table entre
guillemets les enjeux et les tensions
qui peuvent se poser c'est rejoindre
finalement dans cette question autour
des enjeux éthiques de la santé publique
la construction qu'on vous souhaite
avoir et qu'on souhaite proposer entre
guillemets je rappelle que nous ne
sommes qu'une instance purement
consultative comme le conseil
scientifique d'ailleurs sur sur les
années qui viennent
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup donc nous avons plusieurs
commissaires qui souhaitent intervenir
et je passerai tout d'abord la parole à
corinne imbert qui représente le sénat
au sein du bus et c'est n'est désigné
par le président larcher
merci la présidente persie monsieur
président pour pour cette présentation
j'aurais voulu d'abord vous remercier
laquelle vous m'avez réservé aux quand
je suis arrivé au ccn est dire toute la
qualité effectivement je me mets de côté
bien sûr mais la qualité des membres du
ccn et de l'homme de leurs réflexions
souvent très très pertinent très aboutie
qui conduit à l'élaboration des avis
j'aurais voulu aborder le sujet avec
vous tout d'abord la fin de vie
si elle n'a pas qui n'a pas figurer dans
le projet de loi bioéthique selon les
recommandations et la vie du csn qui
proposait de ne pas modifier justement
les équilibres de la loi tess leonetti
de 2016 et qui pour autant revient en
débat au parlement à travers des
propositions de loi quelle analyse
faites-vous des enjeux de ce débat
et quelle est votre approche en tout cas
votre votre analyse
d'une culture palliative certainement
pas assez développé dans notre dans
notre pays et puis alors un deuxième
sujet vous avez aussi évoquée qui sont
les enjeux éthiques de la vaccination
contre la copie 19 donc qui est un sujet
là aussi d'actualité mais en insistant à
à quelques séances plénières du ccn jeu
c'est l'état de réflexion et de
l'avancement de la réflexion du ccn vous
l'avez vous même évoqué tout à l'heure
est ce qu'elle est ce que vous pouvez
nous nous lâcher en avant première
quelle quelle vision du ccn sur
l'obligation vaccinale et le pass
sanitaire je vous remercie
nous allons prendre plusieurs
commissaires xavier iacovelli quai en
visio
non bon écoutez en bernard jomier et on
verra si si on peut retrouver xavier
iacovelli merci ma présidence je voulais
compléter enfin peut-être préciser la
question de corinne imbert sur la fin de
vie j'ai la même interrogation mais est
ce que le ccn e s que vous avez une
réflexion sur comme le débat reprend on
a eu on a étudié une proposition de loi
au sénat
il ya peu de temps il y en a une autre
qui va être étudié le 8 avril à
l'assemblée nationale comment le ccnr
estimerait la reprise de la réflexion
sur ce sujet ma deuxième question
portent surtout sur la révision des lois
de bioéthique
donc vous avez rappelé le processus que
les csn a mené d' états généraux
et pourtant il ya quand même enfin iliad
c'était un processus tout à fait utile
et intéressant et novateur et pourtant
les thèmes qui avait été proposé par la
cce n'ont pas tous été retenus au fond
dans le projet de loi alors vous avez
cité le thème environnement et santé
et c'est quand même marquant de voir que
le csn attirer l'attention sur
l'importance de ce thème un an avant que
n'éclate la crise sanitaire et que ne
reimer je ne sois reformuler le concept
de d'une santé de one health en anglais
qu'est-ce qui nous qu'est ce qui est
votre avis ne serait améliorée pour que
la phase préparatoire à la loi de
bioéthique à la révision des lois de
bioéthique nous permettent
collectivement de mieux identifier les
éléments essentiels à traiter et de
mieux générer aussi parce qu'il me
semble que ça devrait être le sens d'une
construction des lois de bioéthique
s'est décidée autant que faire se peut
de construire des consensus sur les
questions qui sont posées à notre à
notre société
et bien saviez iacovelli vous souhaitez
merci présidente bonjour professeurs moi
j'avais deux questions mais regroupées
en une
notamment sur la question du projet de
loi bioéthique qui comprenait des
dispositions fortes et je pense
notamment à la question de l'ouverture
de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation à toutes les femmes
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république le comité
consultatif national d'éthique
à cet égard rendu un avis favorable à
l'ouverture de la mp à toutes les femmes
[Musique]
considérant que cette cette ouverture
avait là des personnes sans stérilité
pathologique peut se concevoir pour
panier à une souffrance induite par et
fécondité résultant de relations
personnelles et on a vu que cette
question et c'est parfaitement légitime
a provoqué un vif débat au sein de notre
assemblée
ce fut également le cas pour lens d'un
dernier sur la question de 2 commence à
la fin de vie ouh la la commission avait
donné un avis plus nuancé que sur live
et donc ma question est la suivante
comment est-ce qu'on peut rendre plus
lisible plus accessibles les lundis de
du cce afin de que l'ensemble des
français puissent à la fois connaissance
et sans saisir pleinement et le ccme
vous l'avez remarqué tout à l'heure à
plusieurs reprises a souhaité animer des
consultations citoyennes sur un certain
nombre de sujets ans notamment aux
évolutions de dons de gamètes et qui a
eu du coup d'oeil et conférences de
citoyens s'étaient cas aussi sur la fin
de vie
est-ce que vous souhaitez poursuivre ces
chantiers et comment selon vous on
pourrait associer davantage les français
avant travaux merci je vous laisse
répondre monsieur le président fera une
autre série de questions je sûr
fin de vie peut-être cette question
était revenu alors je vous rappelle que
dans notre compréhension du du ccn 7 ce
thème ne faisait pas partie de la
révision de la loi de bioéthique
nous avions souhaité néanmoins compte
tenu que c'était un jeu direct
questionnement de nos concitoyens que
nous pour la première fois je vous
rappelle on était là en janvier 2018
nous avions souhaité que puisque nous
lancions un débat de ne pas passer à
côté de ce débat là même si entre
guillemets nous savions que il ne serait
probablement pas inscrit dans le cadre
de la loi de bioéthique de façon quasi
un peu institutionnels donc c'est ce qui
a été fait donc ceux parmi les
différents grands thèmes de 2,2 des
états généraux de la bioéthique et qui a
été repris à la fois dans le compte
rendu par le cndd et des différentes
différentes
ce qui avait été évoqué dans l'est dans
le cas de ces états généraux puis de
notre avis d'éclairage entre guillemets
sur l'enjeu de la loi de bioéthique
ce thème a été a été fixé en tant que
tel alors notre position à l'époque
était de dire que la loi claisse
leonetti était insuffisamment connue
insuffisamment appliquée à la fois par
les professionnels de santé et
insuffisamment connue des familles et
qu'il était urgent de mettre en place
là je dirais la réalité et le caractère
un peu opérationnels de ce qui étaient
contenues dans cette loi
donc qui était finalement un constat
d'une situation france qui est un peu
différente de celle dans d'autres pays
vous le savez aussi bien que moi avec
une white laisse les onetik est assez
solide entre guillemets mais quitter
n'était ni connu ni appliquée
ça a été la position du ccn eux je
dirais sur l'année finalement content on
l'a écrit en privé en octobre 2018 alors
nous ne sommes pas revenus sur le sujet
depuis il ya eu d'autres sujets entre
guillemets qui sont on y revenus mais de
façon très indirecte 1 sur le groupe en
tout cas autour de 2 des questionnements
autour des ehpad et de co vide mais où
sommes nés et de la notion du tri mais
c'est s'est pas fondamentalement la
question évidemment que vous me posez
donc j'ai bien perçu que cette question
reste est prégnante et que probablement
il fallait malgré les difficultés que
l'on y retourne donc nous sommes en
train et c'est l'addition sera prise
probablement dans les jours qui viennent
de constituer un nouveau groupe de
travail sur le sujet de façon à avoir
une prendre un peu de temps c'est je ne
répondrai pas le csn ne répondra pas à
la question
de tels projets de loi la court terme ou
pas ce n'est pas l'objet savait qu'on
s'inscrit plutôt dans une vision de
réflexion un peu de moyen et de long
terme et que c'est probablement plus
notre fonction que d'être dans
l'opérationnel même si on n'y rentre est
un tout petit peu sur certaines
questions autour de la crise sanitaire
est donc ce groupe devrait pouvoir
repartir
je dirais dans les sera parti en mettant
du du mois d'avril avec une réflexion
qui va s'inscrire sur plusieurs mois sur
les enjeux de la vaccination
oui le csn souhaitait s'emparer de 2,3
ce sujet - étant des bords d'ailleurs
sinon pour informer on en était donnée
de l'information etc mais pas de rentrer
d'autres sur le fond de la réponse le
autour de trois questions à très actuel
autour de deux vaccins une fois de plus
rappelons que le cce est là pour à
partir de données scientifiques de
données opérationnelles qui sont
apportées par les différents comités
vaccin avec sait qu'ils existent
il n'est pas là pour dire ce qu'il faut
faire il est là pour poser certaines
questions éthiques sur certains sujets
et il a décidé de d'aborder trois points
le premier dans les ehpad alors même
qu'on à 85 % voire même peut-être un peu
plus dans certains ehpad de sujets
vaccinés que les règles
d'assouplissement qui ne relèvent pas du
tout du ccn
mais de mesures réglementaires donné par
les ministères sont en train de se
mettre en place avec une certaine forme
d'hétérogénéité selon les régions selon
les directeurs d'ehpad selon les
cultures et on a souhaité aborder la
question de comment quel degré de
liberté pouvait être mis en place dans
les ehpad en fonction si on était
vaccinée ou si on n'était pas vaccinée
ce qui pose évidemment le droit
individuel de noeuds pour un certain
nombre de résidents d pad 10 12% à peu
près de ne pas avoir reçu un vaccin soit
parce qu'ils ont décidé eux mêmes soit
parce que leurs familles dans des
circonstances où leur état psychique ne
permet pas vraiment de décider
et bien de prendre ses désirs il ya donc
une réflexion sur ce sujet la deuxième
réflexion
elle porte sur vaccination et soignant
d'un sujet difficile en ce moment où
vous le savez qui est que globalement on
a 50 % des soignants qui sont que 50 %
des soignants qui sont vaccinées
contrôle que vides mais avec de grandes
disparités selon les clubs
professionnels
environ 70% pour les médecins et environ
30 35 % 40 % pour 45% pour les
infirmières et 30% plutôt pour les aides
soignantes ou voulez ou par exemple les
personnels médico-sociaux en ehpad et
les choses les choses changent parce que
ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on a proposé
aux soignants qu'un type de vaccin quel
est ce qu'ils ont eu un accès véritable
au vaccin donc avant de parler des
obligations
regardons les faits les organes ans qui
a été ce qui a pu être proposées je ne
rentrerai pas dans les détails puisque
ce thème une opinion qui doit sortir
dans les 48 heures mais je vais tenter
quand même de vous répondre
l'idée générale est de ne pas rentrer
dans une stratégie d'obligations des
soignants de leur rappeler par contre
les les aspects de déontologie
professionnelle sur lequel ils doivent
s'appuyer et qui font la beauté de leur
métier mais que don doit arriver
progressivement par un bibi sion entre
guillemets à avoir une couverture
vaccinale beaucoup plus importante chez
ce faisant c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est
doucement en train de se faire à partir
du moment où on va pouvoir leur proposer
en particulier des vaccins à merano et
enfin le dernier point qui était un
début débauche de réflexion et sur le
passe sanitaire où on discute d'abord de
démo delà de la nosologie entre
guillemets entre le passeport sanitaire
qui au niveau européen mais passeport ça
veut dire passer la frontière c'est
probablement pas le bon mot le
certificat de vaccination ou bien le
pass sanitaires alors deux choses il est
urgent de réfléchir il est urgent de ne
pas prendre
cision je vous rappelle que on sait
depuis très peu de temps et encore avec
des données qui sont solides mais pas
très solide que le vaccin protège contre
la transmission
on ne savait pas en série que les
vaccins protéger contre la survenue de
formes graves mais on ne savait pas si
le protéger contre la transmission 12
d'ailleurs les recommandations qui
continue de contourner vacciner de se
protéger de protéger les autres
mais les données israélienne et les
données anglaise suggère qui a une
protection des transmissions d'environ
60% donc à laterrière du pass sanitaire
pourrait être la notion et j'ai reçu
avec 5 je n'ai pas reçu de vaccin
j'ai été infectés par le vide où je n'ai
pas été infectées et donc il me reste
des anticorps et éventuellement
protecteur et j'ai fait un test 48
heures avant qui me permet de dire que
je ne transmet pas entre guillemets au
moment où je vais dans tel ou tel
endroit
alors donc si on aimerait bien que ça
dépasse uniquement la vision vaccinale
et que ça pose ensuite des questions
d'un point de vue éthique entre
guillemets de responsabilité
individuelle mais aussi de liberté entre
guillemets de de choisir tel ou tel type
de situation ça pose aussi des questions
autour de 2 finalement de faire
attention à une série de 2 2 et
éventuellement de bouleversements qui
pourraient être données par l'outil qui
serait utilisé pour ce qui sera un outil
numérique qui pourrait être simplifié
certes mais qui touchent finalement un
certain nombre de données individuelles
qui ne sont pas si simple que ça et puis
à linverse et à titre personnel je
ressens que cette question elle est
éminemment sur la table et que nos
concitoyens vos attentes ça je dirais
pour éventuellement trouver des éléments
de sortie de crise et en particulier
pour les plus jeunes
problème pour l'instant qui a été
vaccinée et avec raison
ce sont les plus anciens donc si on
monte quelque chose autour du pass
sanitaire on pourrait avoir un pass
sanitaire pour les plus anciens qui sont
les personnes vaccinées est de nouveau
une population jeune qui ne serait pas
qu'ils n'auraient pas eu accès au vaccin
donc est il éthique entre guillemets de
proposer un pass sanitaires pour une
population qui n'a pas eu jusqu'à
maintenant accès au vaccin
donc voilà les premiers éléments de
réflexion alors ensuite sur sur les
autres questions environnement et santé
oh oui c'est un sujet évidemment qui est
quitte à mes yeux très fort et la vision
de deux winners on l'avait déjà abordé
la la loi va nous permettre entre
guillemets quand elle sera votée de
d'être dans le champ de santé
environnement on a d'ailleurs fait
rentrer deux membres dont parmi les
nouveaux membres du cce qui qui sont
sûres sur ce sujet et c'est un des c'est
un des points que que je souhaiterais
aborder dans le cadre de européens dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure et la
présidence de la france pour l'année
pour le premier semestre 2011 22 en
partenariat avec les allemands les
autrichiens les belges qu'on aborde sur
sur ce sujet comme
comme comme élément de comme élément de
de partage commun qui peut être plus
facile à aborder que d'aller sur les
sujets de fin de vie ou de génomique en
commun puisque les tic l'europe de
l'éthique n'est pas encore totalement
présente il faut qu'on dirait il faut
aller vers mais il reste des ddd enjeux
culturels qui sont qui sont différents
le projet de loi de bioéthique et
l'ouverture sur éthique et citoyens et
comment on finalement faire que le ccn
qui est un beau une sorte de club de
réflexion d'intellectuels voyons les
choses en face un peu parisien comment
doit-il s'ouvrir comment on doit ouvrir
les fenêtres
eh bien ça je l'avais exprimé dès que
j'ai pris la tête du ccn eux et on
commence à y arriver je voulais indiqué
les états généraux ont été une bonne
occasion de le faire et là le
partenariat avec les horaires et la cnps
air-air s'est mise en place une série
ils participent les les les
représentations des deux de ces espaces
éthiques régionaux participent aux
séances du cce ne participe à des
groupes de travail et ensuite fonds
discuter un certain nombre de sujets
dans un certain nombre de points de
province ça débute cc encore peu
visibles mais c'est en train de se
mettre en place il ya une prise de
position en leur commande à la suite
d'une recommandation du bus et c'est
n'est sur les enjeux éthiques de la
crise dès le 13 mars 2020 sur la place
des espaces éthiques régionaux pour
aider l'ensemble des équipes dans les
ehpad ou dans les services de
réanimation et on va repartir dès que la
loi nous nous en donnera la possibilité
avec j'espère quelques moyens car pour
tout ça il faut quand même un minimum de
moyens repartir sur un débat général sur
je dirais sur un cycle de trois ou
quatre ans qui permet deux choses parce
que c'est une des questions qui est
souvent posée est-ce qu'il faut rester
avec le modèle de la loi de bioéthique
tous les cinq ans ou est ce que la
science avance trop vite et qu'il
faudrait quelque chose au fil de l'eau
c'est une des questions que vous posez
souvent moi je crois qu'il faut les deux
la loi de bioéthique à l'amérique tous
les cinq ans ou tous les
le la date que vous choisirez de fixer
les choses et d'être avec un temps donné
de réflexion tout le monde se met autour
de la table et on a un temps donné pour
créer la réflexion et puis par ailleurs
il ya des sujets qui vont très au fil de
l'eau et qui veut qu'on permettra
d'aborder avec les horaires et la
clairette très bien donc nous allons
poursuivre avec 4 4 sénateurs olivier
neau on remercie madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président de mettre
toujours le débat au bon niveau avec une
certaine décontraction qui rend nos
débats assez plaisant je reviens pas sur
la question du la fin de vie mais
j'avais moi même été assez marquée par
une expression qui avait été la vôtre on
vieillit mal
dans notre pays on vieillit mal en
france et donc bien évidemment cette
question reste posée
le deuxième enjeu est au fond ça pose
aussi la question de la gouvernance
vous aviez exprimé à vrai que gravité
les questions à venir que poser la
rencontre du numérique et des
biotechnologies et donc à partir de là
du point de vue de la gouvernance il me
semble puisque vous avez posé cette
question qu'on a un début de réponse
mais je pense aussi que cette question
de biotechnologie et vous aviez évoqué
les thérapies contre le cancer à des
coûts exorbitants aux états unis et des
gens qui vont dès lors bien immobilier
pour pouvoir soigner leurs enfants et
donc la question de l'accès aux usines
et aux innovations thérapeutiques et
avec gravité je pense une question qui
se pose à l'avenir dans le monde entier
dans l'eau en europe et en france et sur
la bioéthique
vous avez évoqué l'enjeu européen mais
je suis toujours assez surpris que sur
ces enjeux là on n'arrive pas à avancer
un peu plus haut en matière de
coopération internationale même
européens bien sûr mais de coopérations
internationales je vous remercie
merci michel meunier la présidente
monsieur
votre président delfraissy vous êtes
complet dans vos réponses et c'est vrai
qu'il ya peu d espaces après pour en
poser d'autres puisque vous avez déjà
largement abordé les questions
moi je partage votre humour monsieur
delfraissy et il va sûrement falloir en
ce moment pour vous est ce que je
souhaite c'est que président du conseil
consultatif national d'éthique est
peut-être plus de considération enfin en
tout cas soient mieux traitées par fois
que le président du conseil scientifique
et voilà on espère que la bientraitance
la normale faisant c'est l'autonomie
soit respectée voilà de la part de notre
gouvernement ceci dit peut-être que donc
mes collègues ont posé des questions sur
les fondamentaux conseil d'éthique que
sont ces sujets autour de la pma de lits
vgd les délais vous avez donné la vie
sur la fin de vie
vous avez vu aussi que les
parlementaires se saisissent est à
nouveau de ce sujet je vais peut-être
vous amener encore plus que ne l'a fait
notre collègue iacovelli sur la question
de démocratie sanitaire
bien sûr les espaces régionaux des tic
bien sûr l'attention que vous ne cessez
de 2,2 mètres mais comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait aller plus loin peut-être dans
la composition du ccn lui-même pour que
ce soit moins ce club que vous qualifiez
de réflexion d'intello parisien alors je
me comme j'ai été je ne me reconnais pas
ni en parisienne ni un intello voilà ni
en spécialiste je ne suis pas voilà mais
j'ai été très heureuse d'être membre de
ce comité d'éthique et est de constater
que
les quelques apports que je pouvais
faire était était de l'ensemble des
collègues qu'ils aient plutôt bien perçu
et surtout souhaitait être modélisée ou
en tout cas dupliquer donc voilà sur cet
aspect de démocratie sanitaire
monsieur président est-ce que vous avez
des propositions concrètes à faire pour
augmenter encore ce périmètre en deux
questions fils est mouillé puis alain
milon merci mesdames en supposant que
moi j'ai deux questions une plutôt
d'organisation est l'hôte de
communication vous avez évoqué votre
vision de la façon dont vous imaginez
l'évolution du du comité avec notamment
l'introduction du numérique et de la
santé environnement avec la mise en
place de ce travail par silos moi ma
question c'est est ce que vous pensez
pas que à travers cette nouvelle
organisation c'est aussi un peu plus de
lourdeur dans les travaux et donc de
lisibilité dans les travaux c'est une
question plutôt d'organisation par
rapport à ces thématiques qui sont
essentielles qui sont en tout cas à
traiter ça c'est le point points et ils
deuxième point mais qui est très liée
finalement c'est le débat de la
communication parce que on est souvent
amené à avoir vos avis alors nous les
parlementaires je pense que les
professionnels de son d'une façon plus
générale ça s'arrête souvent là alors
que inversement en tant que président du
cos et scientifique vous êtes
extrêmement médiatique et la question je
me pose c'est que finalement comment
comment imaginer une stratégie de
communication du conseil
au regard de ces éléments là parce que
je pense que c'est fondamental notamment
lorsqu'on doit prendre des positions que
cela ne coûte pas du scientifique ou
politique sur des sujets tels que la fin
de vie par exemple c'est important de
pouvoir avoir un vrai support de
communication sur les haies vives aux
portes et voilà comment vous arrivez à
faire ce discernement entre ses deux
fonctions
aujourd'hui alain meylan oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur professeur
jeu
avoir volontairement des propos
excessifs pour montrer combien il faudra
mener une réflexion l'appui ce possible
possible dans la bande ka de la création
d'un conseil national d'éthique nous
vivons actuellement une crise
extrêmement grave qui à la crise de la
choroïde et la plupart de nos
concitoyens constatent qu'il y a une
véritable dictature des médias avec dans
cette dictature des médias l'arrivée
d'une génération spontanée de
scientifiques de tous bords la création
d'un comité national d'éthique que vous
avez évoqué ne risque-t-il pas
d'entraîner une dictature de l'éthique
qui musèle ray complètement nos
politiques et ensuite il y aura encore
une dernière salve non merci parce que
c'est des cd très belle question puis de
je veux dire qui nous élève tous
un merci sur la dernière que je reprend
finalement quelle structure
je partage votre questionnement vous le
sentez bien ce jeu je me dis à la fois
que bon c'est le comité national
d'éthique a maintenant eu a été créée
vous le savez sous françois mitterrand
il a changé il a vidé des des présidents
divers et variés pas tellement
d'ailleurs un il a gardé finalement une
vision et quand on relit un certain
nombre d'avis 10 à 7 à 8 ans il ya bien
sûr des choses qui se sont modifiées
mais il ya aussi des déconstructions de
pensée qui demeure et inversement le
monde autour de nous est en train de
changer et comment ils enfin une
structure doit à la fois garder sa base
garder ces éléments fondamentaux et si
elle ne change pas si elle ne se modifie
pas une structure ne va plus ces jeux
c'est un constat c'est pas vrai que pour
la bioéthique
j'entends parfois de dire la bioéthique
elle est fixée dans le marbre et la
bioéthique 10 à 50 ans était la même que
maintenant la réponse est à mes yeux non
non parce que la science il ya 50 ans
nenê n'apportez pas un certain nombre de
questionnements qui sont importés
maintenant même si certains fondamentaux
de la réflexion de ce qu'est l'homme
et de ce qu'il veut faire ensuite de son
destin reste évidemment des questions
fondamentales et reste totalement vrai
donc sur le numérique sur sur des
aspects de santé et environnement et on
pourrait imaginer aussi d'autres
pointent enfin sur le vision très
globale de wana finalement que faire
vous avez senti mon hésitation et jeu
c'est l'hésitation également c'est le
président du ccn n'est rien ce qui fait
la force du cnc ses membres c'est la
discussion celle exercice d'intelligence
collective qui se monte de la part de 39
hommes et femmes qui sont d'horizons
différents qui font ça gratuitement
d'ailleurs et qui construit ce qui passe
beaucoup de temps qu'ils écrivent
eux-mêmes pour une bonne partie les avis
qu'ils sortent avec les limites de sa
meilleure et donc sur 7 sur cette vision
le ccn l'umam hésitant je souhaiterais
pas en effet que se montrent un gros
machin à la française comme on sait
admirablement les fers de type un peu
trop administratif et qui soit en plus
une certaine forme de caution pour un
gouvernement de dire voilà j'ai mon
agence de l'éthique et on l'a vu la
limite des agences donc il faut faire
très attention c'est nous tenons et pour
cela les deux d'entre vous qui êtes
présents dans la salle et qui avait
appartenu ou appartenait actuellement
cessez de vous savez que c'est quelque
chose qui revient en permanence cette
notion d'indépendance nous sommes force
de proposition mais nous nous ne
d'ailleurs comme le conseil scientifique
ne le décidons rien du tout on est une
instance qui mais c'est justement c'est
ça qui fait sa force
quand eux qu'on peut faire une série de
propositions il s'auto saisir
donc je ne souhaiterais pas en effet
qu'on passe à une trop grosse structure
de type agence donc le voir nous sommes
dans la réfection il
il faudra qu'on en reparle jeu j'ai
voulu vous en parlait comme un des
enjeux c'est vraiment une des raisons
pour lesquelles j'ai envie de poursuivre
ces deux ans pour m pour au bout de ces
deux ans qu'on conçoit dans la bonne
direction pour pour la suite pour nos
plus jeunes parce que le numérique est
aussi un élément fondamental
il ya d'autres questions tour dans le
vie heureusement qu'ils sont
fondamentales aussi et qu'on mette tout
tout tout ça dans la bonne direction et
avec la capacité de de quelque chose qui
est capable de ramasser un certain
nombre
un certain nombre de points comment
améliorer encore la démocratie sanitaire
bon je pourrais y rester là c'est
vraiment vous le savez moi quelque chose
qui était essentiel à mes yeux de
construction de c'est dans mes gènes si
je peux dire où en plus qu'à le vih est
rentré dans mes gènes donc la
construction avec les citoyens avec les
malades eux mêmes avec les associations
de patients est quelque chose de
fondamental
après tout en disant ça chacun son rôle
l' expertise ça existe la réflexion la
réflexion éthique elle existe un et puis
elle peut être modulée construite
quand vous avez un certain nombre de
citoyens qui vous disent je ne comprends
rien à votre avis je ne comprends rien
qu'est ce que vous avez voulu dire avec
telle phrase c'est vrai que la
construction allait fait dans une
certaine mesure par par un cerf par une
vision de plus tôt intellectuelle donc
il ya juste équilibre à trouver qui est
très difficile et nous avons des
discussions au sein du ccn certains
voulant s'ouvrir beaucoup d'autres
disant attention attention est de
trouver l'équilibré entre respecter
entre guillemets une construction une
fois de plus d'intelligence collective
d'un groupe haddock et et de s'appuyer
sur cette vision aussi des citoyens
je pense que c'est faisable en tout cas
moi j'en ai fait un enjeu vraiment pour
compléter il est déjà bien démarré avec
les avec les horaires et ça permet
d'aller sillonner d'aller faire une
série de réunions sur des thèmes mais
très pointu un mois je je je je disais
tout à l'heure à l'assemblée nationale
que j'ai démarré le 1er débat sur les
états généraux de la bioéthique à brest
1 6 janvier 2018 par un temps de chien
comme il peut faire à brest le soir une
salle pleine dans la mairie mais plus
grandes salles pleines mais il ya
d'autres endroits où il fait pas bon je
suis du cantal il fait souvent pavot
dans le cantal et
sur les nouveaux aspects de la génomique
et chris marquès 9 lassane plein 250
personnes en étaient pas autant du que
vides je me suis dit mais on va se on va
se planter la superbe sortie de là
j'étais remonté comme une pendule en me
disant c'est pas possible nos
concitoyens comme d'habitude sont
beaucoup plus intelligents qu'on ne le
pense et pose les bonnes questions se
situe bien là où ils sont alors ce
n'était pas représentatif de quoi que ce
soit c'était une salle pleine à la
mérite de dans la mairie de brest
mais quand vous avez une série des
bourne a fait plus de 350 bon ça vous
commencez si vous voulez à partir de là
à avoir à partir de votre vision de
réflexion intellectuelle une plus grande
discussion par rapport à ce que pensent
les citoyens mais je veux pas vous
apprendre ça c'est votre job
mais ce n'était pas de notre jusqu'à
maintenant si on l'évolution du comité
sur la lourdeur des travaux non je pense
que avec quelques moyens supplémentaires
il en faudra on peut on peut mener ça on
peut mener ça mais c'est pas non plus
des moyens considérables ces quelques
postes et 1 et un peu de fric de
fonctionnement il faudra il faudra à ce
moment là qu'on nous les donne
mais je pense que c'est parfaitement
faisable le débat de la communication
oui un point essentiel façon on va
sortir deux à la fois dans vous en êtes
bien la perception un de ceux qui
manquent fondamentalement dans la
situation actuelle c'est la confiance
c'est la confiance
et ça me ça m'attriste parce que c'était
une partie de mon rôle mais c'est
extrêmement difficile et la confiance de
nos citoyens vis-à-vis de leur politique
vis-à-vis de leurs décideurs vis-à-vis
de des scientifiques eux mêmes à un
afflux inconsidérée de scientifiques ou
de pseudo scientifiques sans régulation
sans régulation je l'avais cité dans
d'autres ici dans cette salle à
l'occasion d'une autre audition j'ai
porté la question devant devant le csa
sur un certain nombre de deux choses qui
n'est qu'ils n'étaient pas bien en
septembre et qui ne sont toujours pas
très bien là maintenant vous avez
remarqué vous mêmes que dans ma fonction
de président du conseil scientifique je
n'ai pas pris la parole depuis six
semaines
parce que j'estimais que voilà il faut y
abandonner il faut s'auto protéger et se
dire mais oui oui finalement l'important
l'important c'est de ces deux pans cessé
d'écrire c'est de pouvoir donner un
certain nombre comme quand on sait celle
des lions est paré et pas de subir une
certaine forme de pression de certains
médias ou de certains politiques il faut
se sortir de là se sortir vers le haut
donc travailler et c'est ce qui a été
fait il a jusqu'à maintenant
donc on ne sortira pas indemne de tout
ça et il y aura dans le dans le cadre de
santé publique et enjeux éthiques de la
santé publique c'est un des c'est un des
sujets cab aura sûrement le cce ne pas
sol probablement s'appuyer avec d'autres
instances sur sur ces enjeux éthiques
avec une sorte de fusée à trois étages
une réponse immédiate comme je voulais
indiqué autour de voix la déposition
immédiate la vaccin passe et c'est des
choses qui sur lesquels il a une opinion
une opinion plus qui va prendre
plusieurs mois sur sur les enjeux de la
crise sanitaire les premières leçons qui
peuvent être tirées et c'est une vision
plus globale autour d'enjeux éthique de
la santé publique et qui prend le temps
deux parce que c'est un des questions du
ccn ne sait comment
de temps en temps répondre à l'urgence
mais globalement c'est pas son rôle ce
rôle est d'avoir une pensée
plus dans la durée merci également
terminé la dernière série de questions
laurence cohen ensuite catherine
procaccia florence lassarade il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites et
je vous remercie monsieur le président
je pense que vraiment effectivement il
ya il ya une difficulté à la fois à
renforcer le ccn et en même temps moi je
partage complètement ne pas en faire une
machine lourde comme on a pu le voir et
nous on l'analyse au niveau du sénat
notamment au niveau des agences c'est
toute la complexité mais ça pose les
questions que vous avez cuisez que vous
avez proposé
moi je trouve porte quand même
j'aimerais avoir un peu plus de
précisions sur votre conception de
comment dirais-je d'éclairer en fait les
savoirs mais pour une appropriation
beaucoup plus collective parce que vous
avez vous avez raison vous l'avez dit
même si j'ai entendu que vous avez
organisé un certain nombre de débats
en fait les débats qui peuvent avoir
lieu au sein de votre instance ne sont
pas partagées par l'ensemble du des gens
du public des citoyens dit citoyenne et
quelles initiatives donc on peut prendre
et ça répond pour une pour une toute
petite part à la réflexion de notre
collègue alain milon en voyant
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement et
notamment par les médias nous sommes
abreuvés d' expertise de faux experts ou
de ceux qui se bombarder comme étant des
experts mais il ya besoin à un moment
donné d'avoir une parole qui est une
parole qui a été élaboré en commun par
un groupe ii
d'intellectuels de scientifiques et
qu'ils partagent et dans la façon dont
dont vous abordez les choses c'est
d'autant plus important que on est en
plein au coeur du respect de la dignité
humaine du respect du devoir de
solidarité de justice et donc à partir
de là il est enfin pour moi absolument
indispensable de voir comment est ce que
ça peut être partagée par le par le plus
grand nombre donc quelles initiatives
peuvent peuvent être prises sur cette
question là de même vous avez appelez de
vos voeux dès le début de votre propos
votre souci d'avoir une place un
rayonnement je sais pas comment
l'exprimer mais dans un partage au
niveau international et d'ailleurs vous
faites partie du comité éthique de l'om
est ce que je trouve être tout à fait
positif
comment est-ce que vous en jeu vous
envisager les choses et puis c'est vrai
que dans moins personnellement je fais
partie des sénateurs et des sénatrices
qui avons été très dubitatif devant le
fait que nous ayons vu la pma qui s'est
retrouvé dans le dans le temps dans les
lois de bioéthique alors que nous
aurions préféré qu'elle ne s'y trouve
pas donc comment est ce que vous vous
envisagez cet élément est enfin toute
petite dernière question pour garder
notre humour partager effectivement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur la dualité de vos deux fonctions je
vous remercie
catherine procast ya donc les mois il ya
eu tellement de visioconférence que je
ne sais plus comment utiliser le micro
monsieur le président vous avez donc
évoqué la composition du ccn
j'aimerais savoir puisque les 38 autres
personnes qui en font partie sont nommés
si vous pourriez souhaiter que
l'évolution de la composition du cc ne
change ou intègre un certain nombre de
personnes qui n'en font pas partie
actuellement une deuxième question vous
avez rendu récemment un rapport sur les
accès aux médicaments innovants moi je
voudrais vous poser la question de
l'accès aux médicaments anciens c'est un
peu donc l'unité parce que simplement ce
matin j'ai présenté une note de l'opex
sur la phagothérapie et on a bien vu
quels étaient les problèmes d'accès des
médicaments à des soins qu'ils ne sont
plus homologué maintenant est la
troisième question là on pouvait laisser
mes questions sont tout azimut
je voudrais vous parler des français de
l'étranger dans un premier temps
récemment le gouvernement avait décidé
que les français qui habitait qui
vivaient hors d'europe n'avaient pas le
droit d'accéder de venir en france alors
que les français qui vivait en europe où
les européens qu'ils pouvaient venir en
france chacun sous présent après
présentation d'un test pcr
or les français sous prétexte qu'ils
étaient hors europe n'avait plus le
droit d'accéder
le conseil d'état a annulé la semaine
dernière cette disposition mais je
voudrais savoir si en termes d'éthique
ça pourrait faire partie de vos
réflexions et des réflexions concernant
ben
le traitement égalitaire des français
puisque en plus un bon nombre d'entre
eux ne peuvent sans doute pas bien se
faire soigner dans les pays dans
lesquels ils habitent
merci très bien florence lassarade oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur
président toutes les questions ayant été
posées moi j'en ai une qui a rien à voir
avec le sujet pour quelle raison fin
janvier lorsque vous préconisiez un
confinement strict et pendant les
vacances de printemps
vous n'avez pas été écoutés et avant de
vous laisser la parole moi j'avais prévu
3 3 questions qui n'ont pas été posées
par mes collègues dont je me permet de
les déposer très rapidement de la
première c'est comment vous avez évoqué
un peu en effet la place de la france en
matière d'éthique mais comment vous
situez la réflexion française en terme
de comparaison internationale
et on a vu notamment ce prix nobel
attribué à une chercheuse française prix
nobel de chimie sur le génome humain
mais que
qui a dû aller poursuivre ses recherches
et faire toutes ces recherches à
l'étranger et qu'avait il n'avait pas
suscité en france vraiment de réflexion
structurée ça c'est le premier point
la deuxième question c'est sûr la crise
sanitaire nos collègues députés ont
adopté une proposition intitulée éthique
de l'urgence qui prévoit une
intervention plus systématique du ccn
sur les mesures prises en quatre plus
pensez vous qu'un tel dispositif enfin
qu'un tel texte soit utile de la mesure
il me semble que le ccdh et pouvaient
saisir et s'est déjà saisie d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises de questions qui
semblait importante est la troisième
question c'est aussi lié à la crise
sanitaire
nous sommes tous sollicités nous avons
tous connu des cas tout à fait tout à
fait spécifique et douloureux de
familles de résidents départ douze
personnes hospitalisées qui n'ont pu
n'ont pu voir leur faim lors leurs
parents en toute fin de devis et qui
demande une forme de droit opposable à
la visite je sais pas comment l'appel
leurs proches
donc comment vous envisager cette
question est comment on peut répondre à
cette demande de forte qui peut paraître
en effet une question de bon sens et
d'humanité de par les directeurs d'ehpad
où vous parlez
les hospitaliers mais comment vous voyez
est ce qui est ce qu'il faut vraiment
légiférer sur ce sujet ou est ce qu'on
peut est ce qu'on peut trouver d'autres
solutions
voilà monsieur le président
peut-être d'abord sur tout ce qui était
autour de fonctionnement du csn
composition du cca ne donc je vous
rappelle on est je vous ai je l'avais
envoyé au bureau le un livret d'accueil
que vous pourrez avoir sucé passive où
l'on distribué que nous allons
distribuer aux nouveaux entrants du cce
là au mois de janvier qui refaisait le
point finalement sur le le mode de
fonctionnement comment nous travaillons
donc 39 membres il ya à peu près
d'égalité homme femme
il ya une hétérogénéité a cessé
multidisciplinaire je voulais déjà
indiqué il ya environ à peu près 50% de
deux jeunes retraités et 50 % d'actifs
[Musique]
c'est il ya une section technique qui
présidait pas un président de section
technique qui fait le fait le job je lui
dirais de ramasser un peu de l'ensemble
des demandes et je vous rappelle que
finalement n'être cette notion
d'indépendance entre guillemets puisque
il ya une domination par les ministères
au rheu par différents organismes de
recherche
elle tient à la fois la personnalité des
gens sains et ceux qui sont le savent
donc qu'ils sont passés au ccd de ça
elle tient aussi au fait que l'on peut
s'auto saisir des sujets et qu'on s'auto
6 ans de 11 cantons s'autosaisit d'un
sujet évidemment on est maître de ce
sujet mais il est important aussi qui
est des saisines à la fois des
organismes de recherche et on l'a et du
gouvernement si c'est nécessaire et
qu'on a une saisine aussi qui peut
remonter et c'est ça qu'on a mis en
place de la part de comités d'éthique de
provinces et des régions et à partir des
horaires sur un certain nombre de sujets
donc faut-il modifier la composition
il ya une discussion de faire rentrer
des citoyens dans le dans le comité
national des types
alors moi je suis à la fois pour mais en
quantités limitées pour parce qu'une
fois de plus ça permet d'avoir un petit
nombre
et qu'ils puissent après prolongation un
départ difficile hein parce que c'est
une assemblée quand même où le niveau de
discussion et est relativement élevé et
ils vont donc être perdu un peu au
départ mais il faut pouvoir les
accompagner l'effort mais enfin c'est
une chose dont on donc on avait fait
avec le comité citoyen et après ils vont
pouvoir quand ils vont commencer plus
timidement à poser des questions ils
vont une fois de plus dire aux membres
et puis ensuite ils sont plus tout
timide et ils vont ils vont le ils vont
le faire et c'est pour ça que je suis
très pur il
ils vont nous nous nous interpeller en
disant mais une fois de plus votre texte
assez bien je vois discuter etc
mais moi je ne le comprends pas bien et
finalement pour qu'ils sont faits les
textes du ccn c'est une vraie question
aussi que nous allons en permanence
elles sont pour quel public et elles
sont probablement pour un mélange de
public
elles sont à la fois pour les
scientifiques pour un certain nombre de
d'instance de réflexion un peu politique
ou comme la vôtre
et puis elle est à mes yeux elles
doivent progressivement entrés vers une
vision de partage citoyen mais voilà
c'est ça ne s'annonçait ça va prendre un
peu de temps
c'est la direction que j'ai souhaité
donner au csn depuis depuis maintenant
quatre ans nous sommes nous sommes
dedans et ça va se faire mais ça prend
un peu de temps donc faut-il ensuite à
les modifier complètement non je pense
que ce qui est beaucoup plus important
c'est que nous ayons la présence de
citoyens issus des erreurs par exemple
ou mais pas que qu'ils soient dans les
groupes de travail c'est à dire qu'ils
participent à l'élaboration de la vie à
et les avis se construisent au sein d'un
groupe de travail qui peut qui démarre
dès le début on l'a vu par exemple sur
on vient de le tester la sur
consentement vient de le tester sur sur
certains points des avis sur les vaccins
où on a eu cette vision là dès le départ
et vous donc ce n'est pas seulement
d'être plénier du ccn eux mais c'est
d'être dans les groupes de travail qui
permettent de construire les allées
bon jeu sur les aspects de coopération
internationale je veux pas plus loin on
l'a beaucoup développé on a un membre du
cce qui va être nommé au comité
d'éthique de la commission européenne je
pense qu'on devra avoir qu'il ya
quelqu'un aussi de de nom mais sur le
comité d'éthique de l'onu enfin j'ai
vraiment c'est un aspect que je
connaissais bien internationale sai on
pousse vraiment cette vision de
française pour être présent et là je le
vois bien sûr un certain nombre de
sujets il n'y a pas une grande réunion
sans qui nous sont qui nous demandent
qui est un des membres qu'ils puissent
s'exprimer qu'ils puissent porter là où
nous en sommes etc et les débats par
exemple sur les enjeux éthiques aussi de
la crise on les a eus en particulier
avec l'om est ce vous avec un certain
nombre d'instances donc je pense que
voilà on peut toujours mieux faire mais
on est vraiment on est vraiment dedans
alors sur le sur les aspects de dualité
de la fonction des deux baies deux
fonctions devraient question je n'ai pas
totalement la réponse je me la suis
posée aussi mais si j'ai tranché puisque
je viens vers vous et je passe devant
vous je mets ma vision est la suivante
fondamentalement c'est c'est le cessé
d'inquiéter maquis et ma vision pour les
raids toutes les raisons que je vous
indiquais long terme président du
conseil scientifique
j'avais demandé une fois de plus à ce
que ce conseil s'arrête au mois de
juillet vous l'avez prolongée on est
dans une situation qui est encore très
difficile pour quelques semaines de
trois mois en attendant que la
vaccination arrivent en masse mais ce
c'est pas avant l'été
vous le savez on aura probablement
atteint 30 millions de vaccinés à la fin
juin
d'ici là voilà c'est quand le conseil
scientifique a des vues anticipe entre
guillemets en disant voilà le risque que
voilà le scénario qui risque de se
produire
et c'est ce que nous avions dit en
janvier c'est ce qu'on a redit récemment
on n'est pas des devins
on n'est pas bon on est des gens tout à
fait suer tout à fait normaux c'est
plutôt qu'il ya des modèles qui
permettent de construire à partir de ce
qu'on sait sur le virus et en
particulier l'arrivée des variants qui
permettent de se faire une idée
après et c'est peut-être c'est une bonne
chose que finalement le le président du
comité d'éthique soit aussi présent il a
d'autre enjeu que sanitaire purs et durs
et les enjeux sociétaux et les enjeux
économiques qui ne relève pas de nous
mais qui sont quand même très prévenant
il ya les conséquences pour la jeunesse
qui sont fondamentales et où cette
vision je dirais un peu humaniste de et
de responsabilité de l'autre qu'apporte
le comité d'éthique et probablement
aussi quelque chose d'important
alors on quitte pas un navire qui va pas
bien c'est pas dans mon éthique
personnelle c'est pas dans mon éthique
personnelle alors nul n'est
irremplaçable peuvent remplacer mais on
va on quitte pas un navire qui va pas
bien surtout quand on se dit qu'il ya un
enjeu de cours moyen terme et pas de
long terme je reste positif sur la
sortie de crise à l'automne 2000 à
l'automne 2021 à cause des vaccins on
peut certes avoir un élixir variant les
mêmes cessera on aura on aura les
stratégies avec les nouveaux vaccins et
qui arrive en haut qu il y à cet enjeu
de quelques mois sur lequel il faut les
passer et tout en respectant un certain
nombre de valeurs qui sont nos valeurs
autour de deux de nos concitoyens donc
voila voila j'ai j'ai beaucoup hésité
et parlez vous avez compris pourquoi je
souhaitais rester au sein du cc 2 pour
porter la cette vision pour les deux ans
donc
je répondrai simplement on quitte pas un
navire quand les choses ne vont pas bien
sûr sur les autres aspects auxquels je
n'ai pas répondu sur les questions les
trois questions qui ont été posées
mallat président la recherche française
alors là ils feront redémarre à zéro
puis vous me laissez deux heures et je
vous ferai le point sur la recherche
française non mais c'est ce ce pays ses
gouvernements successifs n'ont n'ont
toujours pas compris ce que c'était
d'investir dans la recherche c'est c'est
extraordinairement nul
cc c'est fondamental fondamental c'est
personne n'a encore besoin et je suis
parle pas d'eux parce que évidemment
chacun a tendance à tirer quand on est
du milieu de la recherche et et du
milieu médical on peut dire il tire la
couverture à soi ou pour ces pieux ses
plus jeunes etc
non pas du tout moi j'ai une vision un
de grand-père là-dessus 1
mais la france n'est pas à la hauteur de
ses ambitions
on l'a ensuite j'ai été à la hauteur des
ambitions sur la recherche sur le vih
parce que ça a été ça a été une fenêtre
de tir la france était en deuxième en
capacité de production scientifique mais
sinon on est toujours en 5e 6e
on est en train de déraper la septième
ou huitième position donc on peut pas
tout d'un coup parce qu'il ya la crise
se retrouverait en 1ère ou 2ème position
ça le fait pas et on le voit bien que ça
ne fait pas d'emploi même charpentier
les parties elle est partie elle adore
la france elle est partie parce qu'elle
a plus de moyens
elle avait plus de possibilités ailleurs
et il ya une série de sur l'éthique de
l'urgence écoutez moi je reprends ce
qu'a fait le cce il y a les enjeux
éthiques le 13 mars
le renforcement des mesures de
protection et les limites dans les ehpad
le cadre le 4 avril les dispositions
funéraire la mi-avril les enjeux
éthiques du déconfinement à la mi-mai
les enjeux éthiques de la prise en
charge de l'accès aux soins c'est-à-dire
le sur l'attention du tri en novembre et
les enjeux éthiques de la vaccination en
décembre enfin il ya eu qu'à une série
de positions dont certains textes sont
une fois de plus j'étais en débord et
mais il ya eu des pressions il ya eu six
ou sept textes du ccn numérique sur les
enjeux du numérique
donc bon il me semble enfin bon
peut-être pas suffisamment visible dans
ce contexte un peu fou qu'on vient de
vivre sur les médias je vous la corde
mais c'est s étaient présents voilà et
enfin sur sur les ehpad
écoutez je l' ai déjà dit publiquement y
compris je crois dans cette salle moi à
mes regrets en tant que médecin est à la
fois ccn et et conseil scientifique
c'est une gestion a suffisamment humaine
est adapté de la situation dans les
ehpad pendant la première vague
je vois là c'est si j'ai un regret c'est
c'est vraiment celui là après voilà les
choses sont maintenant plus se sont
beaucoup plus nuancé le vaccin une fois
de plus on le voit est efficace il a été
largement de prioriser pour cette
population qui ne change rien d'ailleurs
au fait que que cette population
n'allait pas beaucoup dans les
réanimations donc ça ne change pas
fondamentalement la pression sur l'airé
à mais au moins on protège nos anciens
et plus anciens et on va pouvoir leur
leur redonner une capacité dix est donc
dans la vie du ccn qui sort dans 48
heures on aborde ce problème entre
vacciner ou non vacciner dans les ehpad
et on souligne l'importance des conseils
aussi de d'établissement dans les ehpad
pour que la décision ne soit pas
uniquement celle d'un directeur
mais elle soit là aussi partager on est
bien dans un enjeu de démocratie
sanitaire
ah oui les médicaments anciens n'a pas
goûté alors oui c'est vrai nous avons vu
excusez moi j'avais oublié de dans notre
avis nous nous sommes attachés au à
l'innovation peut bon votre question et
pep est pleinement justifié pourquoi
innovation parce que derrière il ya une
innovation il ya le coût de l'innovation
et l'accès à l'innovation et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on est on est parti
de là dessus c'est vrai que sur les
ombres que vous donnez en particulier
aurait failli aux thérapies il y à
d'autres d'autres exemples aussi kiki
qui montre qu'un certain nombre de
médicaments peuvent parfois pas tous pas
tous être recyclés pour d'autres pour
d'autres fonctions mais et ne l'avons
pas du tout abordé dans cet avis t je
vous remercie
nous allons raccompagné monsieur le
précédent delfraissy
mais je vous demande de bien rester en
place puisque nous allons procéder au
vote
conjointement avec avec l'assemblée
nationale et nous remercient encore
président de chelsea
merci
[Musique]